[Music]
is
my name is Darrell sawchuck I'm a visual
effects supervisor here at method
Studios on black panther i was one of
the animation supervisors on the film
[Music]
one of my primary responsibilities was
working with a dedicated team of
animators to craft digital performances
for the hero actors for black panther
and for kill monger along with helping
to choreograph a lot of the third act
battle primarily consisting of fight
vignettes stunt performances the scope
of work originally was you know a lot of
helmet replacements black panther and
kill monger were meant to be entirely
practical suits with some digital
pop-ups but what we found early on on
shooting with that suit started to break
down a little bit and there was gonna be
quite a lot of repair work that was
going to be needed we spent quite a few
months actually redesigning the suit
with the creative team at Marvel to add
more high-tech design and functionality
to the to the suit itself which you know
that meant that the the scope of work
was was drastically changing for us we
ended up doing full-on CG replacements
for for the two main actors there's a
scene in the film where black man theory
emerges from the wreckage of the dragon
flyer in the middle of the battle and
this is a pivotal scene because the
audience comes to realize that black
panther in fact has not died what we did
on the day was we shot chadwick rising
up onto a couple of foam blocks this
allowed us to kind of get the camera
framing and everything sorted out with
the filmmakers and then we went in and
added in a bunch of the digital
components that made up a scene
everything from the background sky you
know cg grass and distant mountains all
of the actual plane wreckage the smoke
and the fire and then of course the CG
black panther suit was all done
digitally we used that the performance
of chadwick in order to get the timing
and the mannerisms of a black panther
but because this the the helmet was on
the whole time in the end this was
completely computer-generated this one
was a combination where we wanted to use
a live-action performance and obviously
the facial performance from the actor a
lot of the same approaches would
transpire we'd go through and create the
roto animation of the character we'd add
in the CG background the sky and then
there was a lot of fine-tuning that we
had to do
for example to get the neck deformation
to be accurate to make sure that the
blending of the live-action actor and
the CG lined up though there's a clip in
the movie where kill mongers clothing is
burning off his body and one of the
first things that we needed to do was
digitally line up our CG version of kill
monger underneath the actors performance
which you can see in that red wireframe
form and what that allows us to do is
when we start doing the effect sim of
the clothing breaking off it can
actually collide with the CG character
underneath so that allows it just to
kind of interact with and ground itself
in the physical space so the design of
the suits for Black Panther and come
longer definitely evolved quite a lot on
the film so a big part of you know what
we need to pull off was that energy
force and and layer that the the feeling
of vibranium technology was something
that was omnipresent across the whole of
the film and we needed to find a way to
in order to capture that visually we you
know ultimately wanted everything to
kind of emerge from or retract into the
necklace of by Panther and kill monger
we did a bunch of systems to make these
nanite particles kind of spawn from and
kind of almost like clapper boards kind
of unfurl across the the character's
body as they form the suit they really
wanted to play the idea that when
whenever one of the actors took a hit
any kind of concussive force that it was
actually storing energy in the suit the
nanites absorbed the kinetic energy and
hold it in place for redistribution very
nice so we needed to show both you know
how that suit and how that energy was
kind of powering up the suit and
actually kind of emerging and then
actually how that was expanding outwards
[Music]
the way in which we start building these
characters is to go and shoot a lot of
reference of the main actors and their
stunt performers of it on set so that
involves a lot of photography of them
you know both with and without their
suits on so we could see how their
muscles were deforming and how their
body would move and then knowing that we
had to do a lot of fight choreography we
actually had them do a bunch of you know
punches and kicks and various
combinations of movements that we had
seen in in both the previous and some of
the early photography a digital double
is a computer-generated version of an
actor or performer or stunt double it's
meant to augment stunt performances that
were done on set or to do Sutra
placements as we need to in certain
superhero films what you can see here is
the stunt performance that we had for
for Black Panther the actor was
fantastic martial artist and was able to
do some of the movements that would have
taken a bunch of animators in a room
quite a lot of time to be able to pull
off the physicality and the realism on
that performance and what you can see is
an example of the environment that we
had on the day there's some blue screen
coverage in the back that would allow us
to isolate the the background extras
that we had fighting it in the
background the CG environment and the
layers that we put into a wakandan
landscape from there we went through and
added in dozens of background digi
doubles in order to make the fight scene
feel much more expansive one of the
biggest challenges that we had on our
plate was making sure that everything we
were doing was going to be able to cut
back and forth with the live-action
photography that was shot in a lot of
cases with these movies you want to keep
as much of the the live-action
photography as possible you don't want
to replace everything just because you
can so there's a scene of the movie
where we're in tight with Black Panther
as he's being pummeled by the border
tribesmen and it's a good example of the
the combination or the hybrid of
live-action photography and digital
augmentation we kept the eyes from
Chadwick and then augmented that and put
the digital suit on top the reasons for
keeping some of the live-action you know
set pieces the rocks and everything in
the background I mean it's always a good
idea to keep as much from principal
photography as possible just because we
know that that stuff is real and then we
you know we augment around it
a bunch of effects and dust elements and
everything to make sure that we sit
ourselves at the scene this is one of
our biggest shots where Black Panther
had to grab the spear and turn around
and fire it off at the dragon flyer and
then narrowly avoid being shot by the
blasters on the way down and this you
know ran the gamut had had every one of
the possible elements of what we had to
do for the wakandan battle on Mount with
Shane gasps so this had a full digital
build for our environments the first
layer that we build out is our digital
map painting of the sky in the distant
background and then we've got a layer of
our CG environment so this is got the
the full terrain that we've we've built
out the the grass the pearl pearl rock
in the background the the building off
to the left and then in the next pass
what you can see is we're adding in the
digital character and then from there
you can see there's a bunch of
effects-heavy solutions or simulations
for dust and debris that get kicked up
in and around black panther as he runs
up the hill when the camera swings
around you can see there's a there's a
crowd of border tribesmen running down
the field the dragon flower comes really
close to camera and then digs in the
ground kicking up a big dust and debris
interaction pass you know all of that
had to be pulled together in compositing
one of the things that we did here but
this shot was originally we I think shot
it as two different takes we use the
first Rhino that runs through frame to
help us wipe the camera in order to get
the the second part of the camera moved
so the creature work on this film was
definitely a challenge to to pull off
primarily because of the specific
locomotion that we needed to do you know
a lot of times when you're trying to
find you know and build up the research
of the actions that are required there's
only so much that you can find online
there wasn't necessarily a lot of
reference of rhinos banking and running
around camera or running around the
corner you know it can definitely be a
little challenging but you know what
we'll do is we build up a library of
basic gates so a walks and you know and
runs that we use a lot of reference for
that we know we kind of have the the
speed of locomotion worked out and
feeling physically accurate and then
what we can do is kind of put that on a
path to have it kind of meander through
the crowd as we need to from there we
can kind of fine-tune the performance to
you know either speed up or slow down
the action that's required but
definitely it can it can be a little bit
more challenging and then some of the
you know the straight digital double
work that we had to do in the film just
because there wasn't really anything for
us to match to so there was a lot more
creative interpretation of how those
creatures needed to move the most
rewarding part of the job that we do
here is as visual effects artists
working in industry these days is
helping to realize some of these
childhood fantasies that you've had
growing up reading comic books thinking
about comic books bringing these
characters to life
it's amazing the tools and technology
and the artistry that we have available
now allows us to really create anything
that we can imagine and not only just
create anything that we can imagine but
also do it photo photographically now
it's amazing to be a part of such a such
a massive movie franchise such a
successful film you take a lot of pride
and pleasure
in that work
you